congratulations to NASA NASA scored a
gold medal on Mars a 10 it was a perfect
launch perfect execution and the
dismount was a perfect 10 on the Red
Planet but that's just the first step of
many steps to come next we want to go to
perhaps the polar icecaps or perhaps
even drill underground if you were a
Martian on Mars 3 billion years ago when
Mars was practically a probably a lush
environment with liquid water oceans and
you realize that the water was escaping
through the ice caps escaping into outer
space or going into the permafrost where
would you go
journalists say follow the money
astronomers say follow the water and if
the water's going to go into outer space
underground or the polar ice caps
you could also probably go either into
outer space to leave Mars or drill into
the permafrost or go into the polar ice
caps so I think that's what NASA is
going to do next of course it's more
difficult to land on the polar ice caps
because the terrain is quite rocky also
Rock retrieval we need to actually take
rocks from Mars and bring them back to
earth because we have tantalizing
evidence that possibly microbial life
existed on Mars we have Mars rocks right
here on the planet Earth and when you
slice them open you see little tiny
squiggly things that look like
multi-celled organisms but we're not
sure it's a raging debate some people
say bah humbug is nothing but a
crystalline structure that seems to look
like a multi-celled organism to resolve
the questions we have to have Rock
retrieval and after that I think perhaps
we should put a blimp or a helicopter on
Mars now the atmosphere of Mars is quite
thin only 1% the atmospheric pressure
here on the planet Earth so the wings of
a helicopter or the size of a blimp
would have to be different to compensate
for that and then of course we should
try for a manned mission to Mars but
let's be real it's going to be expensive
and it will take time it costs $10,000
to put a pound of anything into
near-earth orbit
imagine your body made out of solid gold
and that's the cost to put you into
orbit around the planet Earth to put you
on the moon cost about a hundred
thousand dollars a pound to put you on
Mars costs about a million dollars a
pound so think twice before you think
that we're going to go to Mars with
astronauts in the next few years it's
going to take decades to prepare for a
manned mission to Mars